les députés socialistes n'ont pas pris
part au vote de la motion simplement ils
ont eu l'envié d'en créer une
le parti socialiste a été notamment pris
part à farid autorités pour examiner le
cas de ses députés
est-ce qu'ils doivent être sanctionnés
certainement pas toutes les idées fendre
je rappelais cette signature j'ai eu
avec le premier ministre
c'était dans le cadre du congrès de
poitiers c'est a été le texte qui
fondent les principes la profession de
foi des socialistes dans les trois ans
qui suivent ce qu'on est là je vois mal
qu'on sanctionne des députés qu'on ait
voulu défendre jusqu'au bout c'est que
vous avez l'a promis
je pense que c'est une erreur et puis
par ailleurs au delà de ça l'erreur la
politique c'est de construire des
majorités c'est de rassembler des femmes
et des hommes autour de soi en
l'occurrence ceux des salines pas de
majorité qui sont qui sont très proches